hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 tutorial video in this video
we're going to be talking about is sub
process
and the idea of sub process is it's in a
way does replace other modules and in
another way it's its own thing entirely
but it replaces things like
um like os dot system os uh piping all
that kind of stuff as well as like some
commands basically what
um subprocess is going to let you do
is communicate so so a system as you saw
we could we could send and do some
communication from the shell so your
command prompt bash
from shell
to
a script and get the output from the
script right in this way we can actually
do the reverse so we can communicate
from the script to the shell and get the
output from the shell
so the best thing to do from this point
is to just kind of go over it now up
here i have a raspberry pi that i'm
using and then also i have just my
regular
this is my windows 7. so depending on
you know what operating system you're
using the commands that you run are
going to be slightly different i'm going
to go ahead and see cd desktop here and
then i'm going to cd
and then here we're just staying at home
okay so
so the first thing you want to do now i
just kind of recommend that you
run this in a shell somewhere so you can
actually see the output because if
a little bit through the tutorial will
actually capture the output via our
script in python but to start you don't
necessarily you're not going to always
capture the output so if you're
following along and like an ide at first
you're not going to see the results so
anyway so it just makes sense to me
either command.exe or like some sort of
shell ssh whatever
so anyway with that let's go ahead and
get started so i'll start showing in
windows and then i'll show it in
linux so if you're in windows to start a
python
interpreter you just type in python
and then if you're in linux you'll type
uh either python
um which would give you probably yeah
two seven for me because i've got both
two seven and three installed on this
machine so you hit control d and then
python three
should yeah should give you python 3
interpreter
make some space
there
come over here okay
so on windows let's say you want to just
run a command so a simple command i
think on both you know linux ls and then
on windows der it's just going to list
what's in that directory so
uh let's cover that first so let's say
if you're in windows let's say
subprocess dot call
and we're going to call der
and then we're going to say shell equals
true now what this is doing is basically
subprocess and then dot call it's like
calling this command
der is the command it's calling and then
shell equals true means we want to do it
within the shell you could call it you
could call it in something else if you
wanted that's for maybe a way later
tutorial
for now always have shell equals true
because that's where you want to execute
so we'll call der shell equals truly hit
enter oops sub pro oh silly me i have to
import sub process
okay sub process imported
uh up arrow up arrow there now we called
dir
and as you can see we get this little
output here um if you're in an ide let's
say that's pure python you even though
you did this call you wouldn't have
actually seen this data right here so
same thing on uh
linux
i thought if i did these like enters i
would make space but we're not making
space let me do this then okay so import
uh
sub process again and now um
for linux will be ls so subprocess
dot call
and we want to call this time ls
and shout equals true
so same thing as before and this time it
lists out all the things that are
basically my home directory right
so and again though if were in just an
ide and you ran this on linux you
wouldn't have any output it wouldn't say
anything so now how do we actually
acquire output
we'll go back to windows i guess since
we're doing windows first
and so to do that you would do something
like this so you could say output
equals subprocess
dot check underscore output
and then you do basically the same thing
we did before so we'll say der
and then again shell equals true run
that and now you don't get anything but
we can print um output
and now you get your output now of
course we have like this return a new
line [ __ ] that's coming up
excuse the language uh but so this one's
actually really messy but we can we can
still parse by that you know so you can
you can use replaces and really at the
end of the day you would be parsing by
that um
or splitting by that really anyway so
just because it looks like that it looks
kind of ugly to our eyeballs but for
whatever reason that you were wanting to
do this in a script um it's not that not
that hard now we come back over here to
linux we can do the same thing sub
process dot oops actually we want to
define this as output equals subprocess
dot check underscore output
and again uh same output or not
ls and then show equals true
and then we can print the output
and there you go you get
the things that are here now again this
one's kind of ugly again but as you can
see you've got desktop new line endsmo
newline ocr.high.png
newline python games
so those are just a couple of quick
things now i realized that all we did
was show
running a command and how to get output
from that command but hopefully after
that you can sort of understand how
powerful those just those two things are
because now you can run any commands so
for example
let me show you
let's open up
python3
here so let me bring over um this okay
so this is the list of all of our python
tutorials and here we have our system
tutorial so if you remember we did
system in and all that so i can hold
shift come up here open command window
here and if you recall
i think it was sys.pi which is a really
horrible name to name that file in fact
let's change that to like cis type or
something it never got us in trouble
before but if you ever like learning a
tutorial or
learning a tutorial learning a module
it's really easy to name the file
something like for example
um
when i was practicing like smtp lib uh i
named it i think email or something dot
pi because i wanted to send an email
with it and that conflicts right and
naming something sys.pi conflicts with
cis so anyway that's always a stupid
idea um anyway so it says tut now and if
you remember uh if we ran python
um
and we did sis tut dot pi
and then we said um example
um what syste did for us was it use
assist.argv
and it would take any arguments that we
passed uh through via the shell so again
we're communicating from the shell to
our python script and then in that
python script we're able to grab what
the shell said
um now what we're showing is basically
how to
communicate from the
script to the shell and grab what the
shell said
but we can tie those two things together
so instead what we could do is uh we
could go python so we open up python and
now we're in this directory right so
we're actually in
the sys directory running a python shell
right now
and so what we can do now is say
something like this so import um sub
process
and then we could say
uh output actually let's just run the
command so uh we could go subprocess dot
call
and then we can call
python
um
what would we call it sys yes just dot
pi
and then
check this out
and then we run this in the shell equals
true again
oh
oops uh so anyway check this out um
shouldn't have those little spaces there
but that's okay uh what we can do
instead oh this will get this would be
interesting let's see if i can get away
with this
uh so if you remember we had to encase
all that into quotes let's see if we can
do this
check this out
ugh
oh man i'm angry
um
so it's it's acting like these are all
their own you know every space is the
uh every space is a different argument
normally i'm trying to figure out how to
do that i mean you could do like an
under under case or underline you know
or whatever
uh
underscore that's the word man
call python
i'm not really sure how to tie those
together if somebody knows how to tie
those together so i can
like tie a string together because that
worked before i believe to use i can't
remember i think it was double quotes
before though
um so we could in case let's try and
case this in single quotes and we'll use
double quotes here if that doesn't work
sorry for wasting your time
python
yeah success doesn't feel good
anyway
uh so so here we can see that we're
actually in a python script
communicating to the show running
something from the show passing an
argument through the shell back to a
script so we're communicating from
script to script basically
doing this now there's a lot of other
ways that we can do this
so i live by a naval base and sometimes
they fly fighter jets over not sure if
y'all could hear that probably not
but i could hear that
they make my dog really mad
anyway um
so here's an example of us passing
python syste and then obviously we could
do a sub process
dot check underscore output
and then we can do the same thing again
so python syste dot pi
uh
whoa
picture neo when you say that
um
and then
shell equals true it's hard when things
aren't colored for you
there we go okay so
we've checked the output so we could
store this right to output obviously
we're starting with you know this like
byte code stuff and
the r and the n i think the r is for
return and then obviously new line
anyway um so that's how we could
store the values back so we can
communicate by between scripts now
obviously we can just import scripts
this way
but here's a way where we can actually
communicate to and from
again two different programming
languages very simply just by passing
arguments in and out of uh your command
prompt so
um anyway
enough on that uh just showing you guys
i mean there's just really endless
things it's kind of like when i show you
the url live tutorial
it's pretty basic stuff but when you
combine all the things that you can do
with the internet it suddenly becomes
amazing
same thing here if if you're able to
access the shell you can run any shell
command i mean you could run anything so
here we could go like this we could say
subprocess.call
and then we can actually call um
let's see sudo apt get install python
tweepy okay so we can actually install
modules even this way oops sudo apt get
installed
okay so here
from a python script we're you know
installing packages and all of this
we're able to get away with running
pseudo and all that so
anyway uh i think we'll cut it off here
but just showing you guys i mean this
there's so many things that you can do
um with this ability to communicate back
and forth so anyway i'll leave all those
possibilities up to you if you guys have
any questions or comments
on this video
feel free to share them below i know
some people are going to ask about pipes
i'm going to cover pipes in her own
tutorial video entirely
so
eventually we'll get to that not really
sure what i'm going to cover that but
anyway if you have any questions or
comments on this video please please
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time